one more kind of Tulsi related thing
um congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez held a town hall recently
and it got invaded by you know I don't
want to you I know some people call them
the Tulsi stands some call them the tool
sells I don't know who they are they're
people who just seem obsessed with Tulsi
gabbard and they exploded during an AOC
Town Hall take a look at this
there's a nuclear war which you voted to
send arms and weapons to Ukraine
she's left the Democratic party
okay you originally voted you ran as an
outsider yet you've been voting to start
this war in Ukraine she voted to start a
war in Ukraine I mean what are you
talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
there will be no neighbors if there's a
nuclear bomb so now a second guy pops up
you voted to mobilize and send money to
Ukrainian Nazis now the entire Ukrainian
Nazis thing
are there some Nazis in Ukraine yes
there are Nazis in the U.S as well
there's a lot of not the the U.S
military has quite a problem with
right-wing extremism
um but saying that what we're doing is
supporting Nazis by
slightly helping Ukraine to defend
itself against this invasion of
aggression from Russia you're really
missing the boat
he's telling the right truth you have
done nothing Tulsi gabbard has shown
guts it's almost like they're paid
people but I'm not I'm not saying they
are but it's so outrageous you would say
nobody could really believe this you
must be getting paid you sorry
[Music]
listen there are many Fair criticisms of
Alexandria ocasio-cortez but you're a
warmonger
I don't know that that's really the
right critique for AOC and again
when when you only have a hammer
everything looks like a nail when you're
obsessed with the cult of personality
around Tulsi gabbard
anybody with a different view is wrong
and if it's a warmonger or whatever it
is you assign them that label and that's
what we're seeing here and it's quite
sad one of our sponsors today is busy
box child I know that there are many
parents in our audience this is for you
busy box child offers really great
subscription boxes for kids filled with
sensory toys that will help your toddler
to Elementary age child stay off screens
and do some really interesting stuff
technology use by kids is at an all-time
high especially after the pandemic
playing off of screens is really
critical for development for cognitive
development social emotional well-being
for kids it's an ideal opportunity for
parents to engage with kids as well
Carolyn is the founder of busy box child
she's a mom and a child clinical
psychologist who designs all the boxes
that you receive BusyBox child offers
monthly sensory kits with different
themes for each season or you can get a
monthly sand bin subscription for hours
and hours of fun check out their mini
jars and mini kits for playtime on the
go BusyBox child is a small business
that supports the David Pacman show
support them go to busyboxchild.com and
use the code Pacman for 10 off the link
is down below